this episode is brought to you by
audible try audible for free and get a
free audiobook by following the link
below
[Music]
few issues today are as culturally
divisive as policing
like just about every other aspect of
modern society the police have become a
culture war battleground
as evidenced by the proliferation of
thin blue line punisher skulls and back
the blue yard signs among people who
have nothing to do with the police
police officers are cast as either the
final line of defense against societal
collapse
or a hive of bloodthirsty murderous
domestic abusers
of course as with any topic a bit of
nuance can go a long way towards
reaching a consensus
in this episode we're going to take a
look at the ever expanding role of
police in society
and consider how we might radically
transform the notion of policing to
create a safer better world
as a society we face many different
problems one would assume that in the
richest country on earth we would spend
our money funding appropriate solutions
to those problems
unfortunately that is not the case the
u.s has a long-standing tradition of
reaching for a hammer when another tool
would work better
and when all you have is a hammer
everything looks like a nail
in this country the police are our
hammer domestic dispute
cops mental health episode cops
non-violent drug offense
cops prostitution cops traffic stops
suicide distress calls school security
homelessness civil unrest
it seems as though the only resource we
have at our disposal is the police
and more and more often an interaction
with the police ends in completely
avoidable loss of life
as the ruling class's obsession with
short-term growth takes its toll on the
structure of our society
that society produces more and more
serious problems
people are being forced into poverty at
staggering rates
we're on the brink of a massive
homelessness crisis our schools are
underfunded and under constant threat of
mass shootings
we have unprecedented levels of
untreated mental health issues because
our healthcare is prohibitively
expensive
as these problems continue to pile up
more often than not
the police are tasked with solving them
because of this we've seen police
budgets balloon and officers get suited
up like invading soldiers
intensifying feelings of mutual distrust
between the police and those they're
meant to protect and serve
now before we get into the specifics let
me offer a small disclaimer
if you are a police officer don't take
this episode as a personal attack
you personally did not start the war on
drugs or any of the harmful programs
we've seen implemented across the
country
that being said the uniform you wear is
used as a weapon of the wealthy and
powerful against normal people
people who share your values and
economic conditions
your role has expanded beyond what
should be expected of you
and we need to address that for the good
of the whole society
it's also worth mentioning that this is
not a partisan issue
republicans and democrats share the
blame for the rapid acceleration and
reckless expansion of violent policing
in america
clinton's 1994 crime bill remains a
stain on this nation
and modern republican attempts to turn
the police into another battle in the
pointless culture war has done
tremendous damage to the conversation
about responsible policing
no one side is fully to blame with that
out of the way
let's take a look at a few of the bigger
problems with modern american policing
the first thing that probably comes to
mind is the alarming militarization of
the police in recent years
when the police are called to a scene of
social unrest it's not hard to see why
so many people harbor resentment towards
cops
officers in all black draped in body
armor riot shields thick helmets riding
absurdly large armored vehicles
loudspeakers blaring lights flashing and
guns once reserved for the victims of
u.s imperialism now turned on the
nation's own citizens
police budgets have risen dramatically
in recent years culminating in what can
only be considered local private armies
at the beck and call of the state
the very entity so many police officers
identify as a threat to their liberty
the problem with this militarization is
simple early american police forces were
specifically made distinct from the
military in an effort to win the
public's trust
u.s officials understood that if police
officers were civilians themselves
the relationship between the public and
the police would be much healthier
now all these years later we've returned
to the foolish practice of treating the
police like the military
what's the most important thing in the
world to the average american
their freedom do you think they'll feel
very free when police officers roll down
their street in armored personnel
carriers and humvees
of course not they'll view the police as
an invading army
and the police know this they can feel
the animosity
bitterness and distrust aimed at them
combine this fact with the not-so-subtle
conditioning of walking around in full
body armor and carrying battlefield
weapons
and it shouldn't be surprising that the
police see the public those they're
meant to protect and serve
as a hostile enemy force to be subdued
this tension is why we see so many
so-called
officer-involved shootings people are
nervous around cops
which can make them seem suspicious and
thanks to continuous bad press and
fraternity-style in-grouping
police feel like they always have to be
on alert against the violent hordes
beyond the precinct walls
it's a classic us versus them mentality
now the police cannot shoulder all the
blame here
they're given the equipment and expected
to comply but neither can we dismiss
the very real problems with police
culture the job does tend to attract
violent abusive people studies have
suggested that a full 40 percent of
police officers engage in domestic abuse
and if you want to see how typical
police officers view the public just
visit r
protect and serve on reddit it's
horrific
the problem of hyper-militarization of
police is unique to the us
other countries and certainly other
wealthy industrialized countries simply
do not arm their police like we do
unsurprisingly this has led the u.s to
the top of the scoreboard when it comes
to civilians killed by cops
according to the prison policy
initiative the u.s rate of people killed
by law enforcement sits around 33.5 per
10 million
over three times the next worst offender
but that's just an average rate
the figures become much more alarming
when you look at the actual number of
people killed
in 2019 u.s cops killed 1099 civilians
the next worst offender canada with 36.
then there's australia with 21 germany
11
the netherlands with four and england
with three in other words
u.s cops kill more people every year
than the next five worst offenders
15 times over now it's pretty widely
accepted that u.s police are too heavily
militarized
so we won't waste too much time here
suffice it to say that the link between
militarization
friction with the public and civilian
deaths is well established
to play devil's advocate this is what
the police are for right
to enforce the law i don't really think
this argument can be made in good faith
but let's just say we accept that
premise and move on to another problem
area
if someone you love is having a mental
health episode and you could summon any
person to come help
what kind of person would you pick a
mental health expert right
unfortunately life in the u.s doesn't
work like that the average person
doesn't have access to quality
affordable mental health care
without that resource to turn to the
only course of action for most people is
to call 9-1-1 and hope someone useful
shows up
in the vast majority of cases it's a
police officer or several who show up
cops are trained to give people orders
and defuse the situation
what happens when someone is incapable
of following those orders
orders often yelled and with a gun drawn
in fairness to police officers
this is a difficult situation and one
that they should not be called to handle
they're not mental health experts and
cannot adequately assess the situation
that being said the frequency with which
police officers kill people experiencing
a mental health episode is completely
unacceptable
according to one database nearly one in
four people killed by police have some
form of mental illness
remember those 1100 people killed by the
police in 2019
275 of them just needed access to mental
health care
since 2015 police have killed more than
1200 people with mental illnesses
again the role of mental health mediator
should not fall to the police
instead we should invest in affordable
mental health services at the community
state and federal level
the us remains the only industrialized
nation without some form of universal
health care
which unsurprisingly has earned us the
title of worst health outcomes in the
developed world
by building healthcare infrastructure
which needs to include mental health
care we could reduce the number of
people killed by police
reduce the strain on police officers who
are in over their heads and help
mitigate the stigma around mental health
in america
in this situation everyone wins those
who need mental health care
their loved ones the police everyone
benefits by implementing the common
sense solution of actually addressing
the problem
mental health crises aren't the only
times cops are called to handle a
situation that should be outside their
jurisdiction
they're often called to remove the
homeless from certain areas they're
called in to brutalize and arrest
non-violent drug users
they're sent to solicit and then arrest
suspected sex workers
they're called to handle kids who have
skipped school which often ends with
them injuring those children
we've criminalized mental illness
homelessness poverty even childhood
we can't strong-arm our way out of all
our problems we need to consider the
philosophy of divestment and investment
divest from an already hyper-militarized
and overworked police state
and invest in critical social
infrastructure to actually solve the
problems we face
save the hammer for the nails and buy
some shiny new tools for the other
projects
mental health clinics as part of a
universal healthcare program
drug treatment and rehabilitation
centers to replace lengthy and damaging
prison terms
well-provisioned homeless shelters and
affordable housing to accommodate those
experiencing homelessness
we need to disabuse ourselves of the
notion that defunding the police to use
the common expression
will reduce their ability to function on
the contrary
by scaling back the jurisdiction of the
police along with their excess funding
they will be able to focus on the job
they're meant to do think about it like
a bunch of ice cream cones
right now we have one guy with way too
many scoops of ice cream and
other people with none the people with
no ice cream are having a bad time
watching the other guy
and the guy with too much ice cream is
having a bad time because it's melting
all over him before he can finish it
if we divest a few scoops of ice cream
from his cone and
invest that ice cream in the other cones
everyone wins
they each have enough ice cream no one
is left out and no one is overwhelmed
that is the idea of divestment and
investment in a nutshell or in a cone as
it were
at the end of the day we're not
necessarily calling for a world entirely
without police
but a world without policing as we know
it a world where the right people handle
our many and varied problems
if we do not pursue this radical
transformation our police problem will
continue to get worse
but if we choose to do the right thing
the smart thing
shrink police jurisdiction and invest in
common sense solutions
everyone will benefit and that's
something i think we can all get behind
the conversation around policing in
america is so important
and this topic deserves much more
coverage than can fit in a 10 minute
video
if you'd like to learn more about the
police and how they function in the u.s
i highly recommend you pick up alex
vitale's the end of policing on audible
pro tip you can try audible completely
free for 30 days
and you'll get a credit for one free
audiobook every month so
even if you decide not to stick around
at least go and get a free copy of the
end of policing
it's a great listen and i guarantee
you'll learn something new as an added
bonus
members now have access to the audible
plus catalog with plus you get access to
the entire library of thousands of
audiobooks podcasts and originals
included in the plus catalog
and you can listen to as much as you
want have 10 books you've been meaning
to read
sign up for audible plus and listen to
all of them for just 4.95
i don't think i can accurately convey
how much i love audible
i struggle to sit down and read a book
but with audible i can get through all
the titles i've wanted to
all while running errands or commuting
or traveling for work it's completely
changed how i learn
if you enjoyed this week's video i
highly recommend you check out the end
of policing on audible it's a fantastic
listen
so if you'd like to help support my
channel so i can produce more content
like this
visit audible.com second thought or text
second thought one word to 500-500
it really does help support me and my
channel follow the link below or text
second thought to 500-500
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week